well to the North Atlantic now where
days of rescue efforts for a missing
submersible have reached a critical
stage the estimated oxygen supply for
the five people on board is running out
well the Titan has been missing since
Sunday though it could be floating at
the surface it's believed it's more
likely it's on the sea floor near the
Titanic wreck 3 800 meters deep
well there are now several vessels
involved in the search okay they're on a
live map a new remote operated vehicle
may join the operation well the company
that produced these images of the
Titanic a few months ago is uh sending
its Rover which can operate up to 6 000
meters and has tools to manipulate
objects I'm recording so an article in
National Geographic explorers at Club
say the Rover could help raise the Titan
submersible well here it's being loaded
onto a cargo plane in Jersey this
morning
now Gabriel is on the is in Boston where
the U.S Coast Guard is helping with the
Searcher Gabriel realistically how much
longer do the rescue teams have to find
the sub now
well to find the sub and perhaps find
the people alive inside are certainly
two separate things I mean they can
continue this search effort for the
submersible for as long as they want
quite frankly the Coast Guard said that
they haven't made any decisions yet on
how long they will extend this search
but when it comes to finding potentially
survivors inside the submersible those
five people that is a much different
answer that the chance of finding them
alive uh certainly while there's a lot
of hope that hope is dwindling by the
minute because those 96 hours of Reserve
oxygen that breathable air that ran out
based on the Coast Guard calculations uh
early this morning here local time in
Boston so uh the Coast Guard certainly
thinks that if they were still alive or
are still alive inside that submarine
are submersible that Reserve oxygen that
they've been breathing on since Sunday
when the submersible went missing is
probably gone or very close to being
gone so certainly there's an urgency to
find this submersible as soon as
possible and if possible rescue the
people on inside as quickly as they can
and with that urgency I mean what more
do we know about the sounds that were
picked up through sonar
yeah there was a lot of Hope when this
Canadian uh aircraft picked up these
like banging sounds almost like it was
described as almost someone underwater
tapping on metal that sound that you
would hear uh this was picked up on
Tuesday and Wednesday and the Coast
Guard immediately sent vessels to that
location to search on the surface and
try to search a little bit underwater
but they found nothing the Coast Guard
is analyzing that data from those sounds
but has not been able to conclusively
determine that it did come from the
missing submersible at this point so the
Coast Guard is really saying listen
we're analyzing this they're sending the
data to the U.S Navy to analyze but
they're basically saying we cannot
confirm that those sounds came from uh
the submersible that's missing and they
also caution they say there are a lot of
sounds that come from the OU ocean floor
so you can't read too much into this but
certainly it was the only little glimmer
of hope since this search began on
Sunday
okay Gabriel Elizondo in Boston for us
thank you for that